as you're trying to fix yourself and dig  yourself out of this deep hole that  life society and you helped you helped  also  those people who you saw down there in  that hole who were there with you who  your friends and people who you counted  on  because you meet the people in the same  situation that you're in in life  those people become your friends and  second you try to get out of that  situation and become better  those people are in that in that grave  and that dungeon is yanking at your  heels man saying  oh no get out come on back here yeah you  make it make me feel like  are you getting out of this hole do you  think you are so i get that all the time  now  people would constantly remind me of who  i used to be back in the day